hey guys welcome to the Reuben report I
have Jacqueline Glenn Hank Chen I am
Dave Ruben for the purposes of the show
today that kind of rhyme doesn't that
fun people love rhyming okay let's get
to it so the Democrats have all been
pretending that they're poor and I'm not
just talking about the regular Democrats
I'm talking about the power people
Hillary Clinton and Joe Biden in
particular Hillary of course is going to
run in 2016. Biden may run which I think
would kind of be fun in a Naked Gun way
but also kind of scary so we did this
two weeks ago Hillary talking about how
poor she is and she was so we've got two
clips on her and one on Biden so let's
let's watch Hillary talking about her
struggles it has been reported you've
made 5 million
making speeches the president's make
more than a hundred million dollars well
if if you you have no reason to remember
but we came out of the White House not
only dead broke but in debt
we had no money when we got there and we
struggled to you know piece together the
resources for mortgages for houses for
Chelsea's education you know it was not
easy
okay that's utter nonsense and total
so basically she's saying we
came in with nothing not true I mean
they had money he uh was the governor of
Arkansas Bill uh and then they left
completely broke they needed money for
houses houses how many houses do you
have uh so I'm pretty sure they're doing
okay I'm pretty sure there's no
restaurant that they've ever been uh
turned away from but she continued
first of all we had to pay off all our
debts which was you know you had to make
double the money because of obviously
taxes and then pay off the debts and get
us houses and take care of family
members but do you think Americans are
going to understand five times the
median income in this country for one
speech well let me put it this way
I thought making speeches for money was
a much better thing than getting
connected with any one group or company
as so many
people who leave public life do because
she's so much better than those people
who take money from one she did take
four hundred thousand to do two speeches
from Goldman Sachs uh and I'm not
begrudging her any of this you're
allowed to make money this is America
that's great but don't pretend that you
have no money nor access to making money
in the future and then Joe Biden here we
go now the first thing I was going to
say is look at bite man he's got a he's
got a a mildly expensive suit on
uh
he's vice president United States of
America he makes notwithstanding his
Limitless as a poorest man in Congress
he still makes a lot of money
as vice president United States and I Do
by the way I do
don't hold it against me that I don't
know that I don't own a single stock or
Bond don't hold it I have no savings
account but I got a great pension and I
got a good salary
and uh for real I mean I'm telling you
his presidency would be frank Dragon for
making okay he is flat out lying he does
have a savings account and he does have
11 investment funds they're in his
wife's name so yes technically I suppose
he's not lying but he's lying so where I
want to start with this I don't begrudge
these guys success I want people uh to
be running the country that know how to
do their finances so hopefully they can
help the finances of the country what is
the fascination with pretending they're
poor and struggling they want to relate
to the American people because you know
they feel like that's going to help them
get elected and you know increase their
approval ratings and stuff but I don't
understand why it's so hard to be like I
wasn't always as successful but now I've
done better Hillary could have said that
I mean I know that she was being asked
questions so I kind of view her
situation a little bit differently yeah
and Biden because Biden's just I mean no
one's asking him anything he's just like
I don't have a savings account and I
mean it's just kind of like ridiculous
and like you said it's a flat out lie
why can't they you know be honest and
say you know I can relate because I was
once in that position you know now I've
come out of that but to say there and
lie is not going to help you right now
Biden did say one thing that was true
which is that he was when he was in the
Senate he was the poorest member uh in
terms of having money in the Senate but
like why so he blatantly lies there what
should we do about a lie a politician
lying I can't believe it we'll call
their asses out like you're like what
you're doing here I mean this is they
overreacted just like Charlize the wrong
feeling raped by the paparazzi and goop
feeling like she's at War this is their
attempt at trying to relate to the
American people and it's completely
backfiring and by the way I'm gonna do
an impression of Diane Sawyer In that
clip which is this
yeah
she looked like she was about to slap
the out of Hillary because she's
sitting here thinking you've got to be
kidding me I know what my salary is and
yours is definitely higher and yeah so
Hillary has to pay for taxes and her
daughter's education by the way family
expenses
the houses houses by the way you know
jewelry uh Chelsea Clinton was also at
you know just a couple years ago two
years ago given a 600 000 a year job at
NBC News despite the fact that she
wasn't qualified at all it was pretty
terrible and they basically paid her to
do like three appearances so uh so
that's pretty sweet why do we have uh
success shame do you think because
that's what this seems to me I get it
they want to relate to everybody but we
seem to have this real thing where we're
ashamed of wanting to be successful or
actually being successful I think it's a
carryover from the last election I think
there was so Romney got so much Flack
for presumably presumed is that whatever
the word is having so much money that he
lost an election he was seen as
unrelatable and out of touch and but you
know what to Hitler's credit you know
like at the end of the month guys when
like you paid your rent you paid the
bills you're waiting for like the checks
to come in that's when your account is
kind of in flux I'll bet you know the
with the clintons I'll bet you you know
their accounts are in flux by millions
and millions of dollars and there
there's always that one day in the month
where it might be negative 10 million
like Hillary talked about but of course
she has yet to cash the rest of the
checks and so she's trying to relate
with just that oh God the 30th of every
month I just oh I'm dead broke I think
you're basic that's probably it there is
probably some truth to that they had
debt by the way her Campaign which in
2008 ran into debt you know she had
donors pay off her campaign's debts so
70 t-shirts were they 70 bucks they were
high they were up there especially after
she lost her because they were
collectors items yeah souvenirs
um so the reason I'm doing this segment
is because it seems to me that we're
always attacking Republicans about money
but I want everyone to know that the
Democrats are just as bad do you do you
think that's a fair uh estimation I mean
I think it's fair I mean I I feel like
they're trying too hard to be relatable
because they feel like that's important
but
ashamed of success is really ridiculous
and I think the reason why they're doing
that is because people
you know make them in a position where
being successful could be viewed as a
negative trait in a politician because
oh they'll never be able to relate to me
because they have all this money and I'm
struggling financially why would they
try to go out of their way to help me
right if they can't relate more but to
flat out lie isn't helping and for
people to even have that attitude in
society that success is a negative thing
is ridiculous I can think of hundreds
and hundreds of politicians who are a
contradiction to that I mean no one
thinks about the senate or the House
Representatives all these people who are
making a ton of money and no one
ever says anything about them because
all they can see are the president and
the vice president and these people who
are so much in the public eye but
they're not the only people in politics
and they're not the only people making a
lot of money and George Bush W bush he
had a ton of money you know with his
connections to oil and stuff and no one
ever complained about that because
they're like oh Texas and America and he
can relate to people you know the
Democrats complain he was pretty much an
idiot and no one cared or a lot of
people whenever he was being elected
didn't care because they were like oh
he's so relatable to us you know Texas
and right more like a Texas like a guy
and he knew how to throw a baseball
remember he threw that first pitch out
and he threw a strike to being a
president but I mean most people
among the public office like that
they're gonna be in a position where
they're making money because they've
reached a level of success that other
people haven't right would you rather
have someone in office who has no idea
how to handle their personal finances
and is it in debt you know what I mean
if you knew that the guy that was coming
into president he really up his
financial situation you know what I mean
he's got creditors calling him that's
what they somehow want this that's what
she's saying like we were in all we had
nothing but I would never want that
person to be president right it's sad
that they think that that's the
relatable candidate though they're like
oh we must you know reach out to the
millions of Americans who are in debt
and have creditors chasing after them in
order to get their vote yeah tragic um
last thought on this the lying part just
the flat outline which is what they're
both doing and I get it Hillary's doing
it a little bit less because she's sort
of mincing words and maybe debt and
whatever but he's flat out lying because
it's his wife that owns the stuff and
that's a lie so does that matter even
does anyone even care when they get
caught yeah I mean I don't know how much
he cares but he should yeah because I
mean at least for me I'm not gonna trust
somebody you know how many people trust
politicians anyways but I mean for him
to sit there and say you know it's my
wife's money not mine I mean look at me
I'm so poor I don't have a savings
account it's ridiculous
does the lying matter to you or do you
just expect it I I think it comes with
the territory unfortunately I think
they're gonna pass it off as you know
just politics they told they told a
little bit of a fib or they are they
sort of like the dinner party
conversation where you just say
something to relate to the person next
to you just to make them feel a little
bit better and I don't honestly think
it's going to hurt them whatsoever their
Charming personality and Celebrity
Status is going to get them to the next
level yeah well sadly I agree with you
they have more money than you which is
okay but you know what they're Liars so
vote them all out how about that all
right let's move on uh so this is crazy
you would think this is happening in a
third world country but no it's
happening here in America although we're
on our way to becoming a third world
country uh they are going to start
shutting off water to citizens of
Detroit because people are behind on
their payments because obviously we got
a major uh bad economic situation going
on in Detroit right now uh there is 118
million dollar debt uh in the Detroit
Water and Sewage Department that's what
they have so every week they're going to
shut off water supplies to 3 000 people
which will lead to about 150 000 people
in total we've got a little more info
for you so nearly half of the 320 000
residents who use the utility are
delinquents so they're just not paying
their bills anymore and Detroit's
average monthly water bill is nearly
double the national average of forty
dollars and the Detroit city council
approved a nine percent hike last week
so they're they're increasing what the
water costs is the same time as they
have this tremendous amount of people
that can't afford it uh and we've got a
quote from a member of the the Coalition
in charge of this operation we are
asking the UN special rapporteur to make
clear to the U.S government that it has
violated the human right to water if the
U.S government does not respond
appropriately this will also impact
their Universal periodic review when
they stand before the Human Rights
Council to have their human rights
record evaluated that's Mort Barlow
she's the national chairperson of the
Council of Canadians so obviously
Detroit Canada they're close to each
other so this is a board that's dealing
with some of these issues and they want
the U.N to come in and help Americans
get water
um so I guess the most basic thing here
is we need to just give these people
free water right like we got to suck it
up and let our own citizens have water
this is fair to say world country yeah
what is going on that we're at a point
where we are questioning whether or not
to keep people water withholding it yeah
I mean it's Canadian water too you saw
that Council of Canadians it's Niagara
Water there's a lot of it there's plenty
right there's plenty okay so somebody I
was watching this and I'm sure
somebody's watching this and going well
you know what if these people can't
afford their water then they don't
deserve their water so what would you
say to those people I would like those
people to go a few days without water
and let me know how it works out for
them I mean this is not something that
is you know some something people can't
have like oh this is cable TV they're
not paying their cable bill we're going
to cut off their cable this is something
that they need to survive this is a
human rights issue there are people who
are on life support in homes connected
to machines and it is illegal to cut off
their electricity because they need that
to survive people need water to survive
and what is the alternative they're
going to get sick they're going to get
dehydrated then they're going to go to
the hospitals we're gonna pay for that
what where are they going to flush the
toilets I mean the sanitation was going
to throw it in the streets like we used
to right I mean then there's going to be
diseases and this is going to be a
problem that affects everyone how is it
even logical to want to take that road
it's going to cost more money the
government not doing something logical I
can't believe that but right so you're
on to something there because if you do
shut off the water to these people or
the amount of disease that's going to
increase I mean it's a short-term
Financial answer to what will then lead
to a much bigger
socioeconomic and health problem and all
that yeah what do we do it's I I mean I
think for right now I think we have to
this is one of those issues that really
has to be taken and taken one day one
week one month at a time because we're
talking about something that's so vital
to human survival yeah and right now
listen Detroit if you can't get your
together and you can't afford water
get Obama to pay for it get the
government I pay taxes I'm happy to
contribute to keep my fellow Brethren
alive and while I grad you can pay for
my water bill too because it is
expensive and I can if you or have a low
wage job 80 bucks a month is a lot of
money you know I can afford it
thankfully however I can understand that
it is a struggle because believe it or
not I was once there where I was from
gig to Gig to Gig and your bills it's
it's hard to keep that all in check at
the end of every month yeah I mean as a
comic I know about being behind on yeah
yeah
um
how important do you guys think it is
that we keep Detroit going because
remember during the election they kept
saying uh Biden kept saying uh Bin Laden
is dead and GM is alive you know
implying that Detroit is alive but now
we keep hearing about all this bad
weather Canada maybe they won I don't
think they'd want it actually but but
how important is it that we keep this
Detroit going because it's sort of it
seems to me that it's like the ground
zero of what could really start
spreading across the country if we shut
off water to Detroit or we don't help it
uh come back economically and all that
that's a slippery slope man I'm all for
Leave No Man Behind because then what
are we going to Annex New Orleans are we
gonna add it are we gonna start just
picking territories that we don't like
and get getting rid of them it's it's
that you know we are amazing take them
in I think you mean reverse oh my God
see that would be like this is why you
host the show and I don't addicts would
be if we want if we welcome them in yeah
we're not doing that no we're definitely
not Canada took Detroit they'd be
announcing we should convince Canada
we'll be editing this segment yeah where
is the pride that comes along with like
getting people part of our country I
mean that is part of our country those
are Americans yeah how could we consider
taking their water away and why is that
the first thing that pops into people's
minds they can't pay their bills so we
should take away their water like maybe
the idea of creating jobs or or thinking
of something that would economically
help the area grow like that's not
something that people immediately think
of the first thought that most people
commented on this was cut it off if they
can't pay it they can't expect me to pay
it I'm their neighbor and it's just like
really yeah look at you you're such a
social
what percentage of our bodies is water
like 80 or something 80 or something
percentage of your body is water so
let's just give water to people that
can't afford it we can't do that much
right but I'm pretty sure we could try
to do that
okay let's move on uh a Dutch company
has invented the world's first
electronic joint that's right uh Dutch
manufacturers en joint claim that the E
spliff uh is totally harmless contains
no tobacco nicotine or even THC so uh
just to be clear what's going on here is
the THC that's the part that sort of the
mental High that's going to make you
laugh and all that but the stuff that
has the medicinal benefits is not so you
can get the medicinal benefits without
having the other part of it we've got an
image of the E joint the en joint it
looks uh like an e-cigarette basically
but nice marijuana leaf so you know what
you're doing there not to confuse you
um it's got the uh the shape of real
joint obviously a Chrome plated tip
where the cannabis leaf lights up with
every puff it's available in six fruit
flavors and there are currently uh 10
000 of these things sold every day in
Europe
and you know they want to get it of
course uh to Amsterdam where wheat is
already legal although they've been
taking back some of their rights on that
um pretty good right this this seems all
good we got no problem with weed at this
table I hope
I I'm surprised first of all way to you
know innovate the Dutch you know they
they're the ones that tax the pro that
started tax prostitutes you know they're
they're like let's hey there is a supply
or if there's a if there's a demand
let's Supply it and that's what they're
doing here I'm surprised that there's
only six flavors yeah the prostitutes
literally have a union they're in a
union and they have to go for STD
testing yeah every so often at all they
regulate the government makes money off
it so this could be another example of
that
um so if you took the mental high and
this was just medicinal is there any re
is there anything wrong with this at any
level that you can think of but I don't
think there's anything wrong with just
smoking weed anyways but I mean like I
could see the benefit to this if there's
like a child or something you know that
would need the medical benefits right of
something without getting high you know
obviously you know you don't want to be
like oh here little Johnny take this
weed and smoke it um but if it helps
them you know really pain then I totally
agree with that but whenever I first
read this article to be honest like I
kind of laughed a little bit I'm like
okay so it's got no nicotine it's got no
tobacco go it's got no THC but it's got
like this marijuana leaf on it and
people are like getting all excited
about it people like oh look at this
awesome new thing and I'm like well
first of all I've seen electronic joints
for a long time so this isn't like
something that was new or shocking to me
right but the fact that they're able to
take out all of those things and use it
for purely medicinal purposes is
exciting so that's a good thing do we
need this in America
or do we just need to get or
do eyes period the way it's going from
state to state right now exactly we
should just legalize periods like I mean
the other taxing prostitution and stuff
why don't we tax marijuana I mean that
would help so many things yeah Detroit
take some notes off of Amsterdam you're
real Innovative you know find find new
business ventures to invest in they're
cutting off water in Detroit as we did
in the other segment where maybe a
little weed profiteer and it might be uh
might be good we're taxing the hookers
there's a lot in Detroit yeah what do
you make of the people that I can at
some level even though I don't agree
with them I can somehow get the people
that don't want people to be stoned
because they're going to be stupid and
driving I don't agree with it and it's
there's nothing true about it but but
what about the people that are still
saying no for medicinal purposes I saw
that too they thought it was a Gateway
everything is again
and something else would be you know to
me like I I just don't see it as it's
crazy especially since there's nothing
in this that would be addictive that
would be a gateway to anything what it's
not even going to get you high yeah you
know it's like pretty much taking
medicine so is it because big Pharma is
not behind this yet is that the idea
because we love everything in pill form
so if there were medicinal benefits to
this in uh in this form until a big farm
is behind it you know we never get the
marketing to get everyone ginned up for
it you know maybe two degrees just
because people almost need to be
convinced of things like they think that
oh my God it's got a marijuana leaf on
it yeah people have to feel it's like
they can profit off of it I think I
think once you get a big company behind
it manufacturing it just like big
tobacco in the 80s and the 90s and and
Pfizer and the other big drug companies
once you get a big Corporation behind it
who's you know donating money to major
political campaigns everyone's going to
be back on board especially is as you
guys are saying there's no actual
negative side effects that should impair
judgment right from what from what year
that's what they're telling us and if
they're telling us then we got to
believe them right would that appeal to
you to smoke something that you would
get sort of none of the the mental stuff
of weed but just get the physical stuff
you know your shoulder hurts you smoke
that you feel a little better instead of
taking Advil or something I had a choice
I probably
THC in there but you take
you take or sprinkle it on top I don't
know how that works sprinkles yeah yeah
that'll be something inject some
marijuanas
all right yeah legalizing for God's
sakes every week with the weed come on
kids okay uh oh I think this is really
fascinating so according to a survey uh
released this week by Consumer Reports
uh the word natural on food products
actually means nothing literally nothing
that's right so we've got some findings
from the study
so two-thirds of Americans think that
the word natural on the label of a
packaged or processed food means that it
contains no artificial ingredients
pesticides or genetically engineered
organisms that is simply not true when
consumers see the word on meat or
poultry 70 think it means no growth
hormones were used to get the animal in
the animal's feed and 60 percent think
the animals got no antibiotics or other
drugs in their feed that is also not
true both the FDA and the U.S department
of Agriculture allow food producers to
use the word natural unlabels as long as
nothing artificial or synthetic has been
added that would not normally be
expected in the food under an informal
policy the FDA put into place back in
1993 and the argument's been made that
the prohibition of the word natural
would restrict free speech so we we do a
lot of stuff on this show about natural
foods and GMOs and all the crazy
additives and the sugars and high
fructose corn syrup and all that
Jacqueline I'm going to let you start
here someone with a little science
behind you
um we love words right we just love
words you throw natural on it people
think nature I mean it says right there
that it's just what you wouldn't already
expect to be in the food so something
unnatural is being added to your food
but it's something that they normally
add they're allowed to use the word
natural and put that label on the food
and people I'm sorry but like
I do honestly think that they have the
right to do that people being gullible
is not their fault I mean people exploit
that type of thing all the time
politicians do it and marketers do it so
it's kind of up to the consumer to do a
little bit of work and a little bit of
research to figure out what is in their
food and what is healthy and what's not
and the whole anti-gmo thing too people
get excited they see non-GMO on a food
and they'll buy it I've seen non-GMO on
salt I mean that's an inorganic there's
no g2m because it's not an O so I don't
understand like people just they see
words that are pretty and they think
that they're doing something good by
going after that food right so you're
kind of giving the FDA a little a little
leash here to to fiddle around because
you want it to ultimately come back to
the people and you have to I think it's
manipulative and I wish that it wouldn't
happen but I mean that's on the world
world that we live in and as far as like
the money is concerned you have to
follow the money if this is going to
make corporations more money no one's
going to stop them yeah so I I'm sort of
with you because I believe in the
personal responsibility thing but if
this many people are getting duped
perhaps the FDA needs to do something
more uh more transparent to raise the
standards I I heard you you tell me if
this is correct or not I heard that
apparently there's a certain like
percentage of insects that are allowed
in peanut butter it's like a 0.5
situation just simply because of the
quantity of mass production that you
have to allow that just margin of
toxicity in your well there's a certain
amount of bone that's allowed to be in
the McDonald's meat and stuff because
because of just the volume and so they
have to permit that but what I am
shocked by is just how low the bar has
been set whereas like all natural is not
they're like oh this doesn't have
formaldehyde and you know rat poison so
yes it's all natural and it's it's about
instead of all natural being about what
it is it's now about what it's not
they're like oh well it doesn't have tar
in it yeah so all natural right
um do you think so if they changed it to
be a little more honest wouldn't the
companies the food companies just figure
out other ways of manipulating people
yeah and they I mean that's not the only
thing I've seen you know as far as
manipulation goes I mean I've seen
people you know who are concerned with
animal rights give no mind to factory
farming because instead of factory
farming they say farm fresh and
technically it's a farm it's a farm so
they can say farm fresh and no one bats
an eye at that I mean it's no secret
that 50 of the antibiotics and you know
that are being used go into the food
that you're consuming and instead of
instead of you know marketing like that
they'll say you know due to Advanced
farming techniques we've taken Advanced
Veterinary measures you know and people
see that and they're like oh that sounds
great right but they have no idea that
it's saying we're pumping your food full
of antibiotics right so is that part of
it that especially in America because a
lot of the stuff that we allow in our
food in America is not allowed in Europe
is it part of it that we just love
stamps on things we love like a logo
that says some you know just some
catchphrase or authorized by or
certified by and we don't do any of the
work to when you when you go shopping do
you look for those things even if you're
not even sure what they mean you know
just the stamp on the thing that says it
depends on what it is I think I feel
like I was raised to eat pretty healthy
and so I look you know I look for brown
eggs I look for you know like there's
certain things that I do look at but I
feel like 90 of the grocery store
contains all these chemicals at the
smarties quoting I don't remember but
but how can you avoid it I try to shop
around the outside perimeter get the
fresh veggies veggies and lettuce and
what have you there's But to answer your
question though I do believe that
America is addicted to Brands and labels
for sure we're all you know it's all
about status it's all about you know I I
honestly I think the whole vegan
gluten-free movement really pushed
pushed that kind of obsession when it
comes to one's own diet you know show up
at a restaurant I am gluten-free and to
just declare that to the restaurant so
that everyone knows yeah which actually
now there's been studies saying that
most people unless you have celiac
disease there's basically no such thing
as being gluten intolerant wait I'm sure
there'll be another study that'll
reverse that week anyway so just be kind
of a little more aware of what you're
putting in your body because this
packaging clearly isn't telling you the
truth all right let's move on uh this is
fascinating so half of Americans don't
want atheist in-laws and atheists in
their family this is really nuts I have
a feeling Jaclyn's gonna have a little
something to say about this a Pew
Research Center poll asked Americans
whether they would be disappointed if a
close family member married someone of A
different race a different country
different political party or someone who
doesn't believe in God the scariest of
all things let's look at the study's
findings
49 of Americans said they would be
disappointed if their family member
married an atheist that's half people I
cannot believe that 73 of conservatives
said they would be less than thrilled if
a family member married an atheist uh
and nearly a quarter of Americans who
call themselves consistently liberal and
41 of mostly liberal respondents so they
wouldn't want an atheist to marry into
their family so that's the one I want to
start with a quarter of liberals I mean
we're supposed to be the ones that are
Forward Thinking and uh open to other
ideas and one out of four liberals does
not want you in their family Jacqueline
Glenn go I'm I'm I'm so horrible I mean
I think it just goes along with the
misconception that atheists have no
morals that we're not good people I mean
none of those numbers surprised me
because I've been around this for a long
time I know how distrusted we're like
the most distrusted group of people yeah
in this country there's many studies
that say that people I mean yeah I mean
there there was a study one time where
they asked people if there was an
abandoned car and it was you know if
somebody went through it and stole
everything out of it would you expect
that this person was you know a b c and
one of the options was like you know
rapist a murderer atheist and it's like
oh definitely The Atheist that was the
highest chosen answer and it's like
really I mean whenever all these
different studies are lined up we are on
par with rapists and murderers as far as
you know the lack of trust goes and it's
it's fascinating and I think most of
that's just because there's such a
stigma behind it because people think
that you have to have religion to have
morality or some sort of spirituality
and to say that you know you're on your
own without that is is very scary to a
lot of people yeah so quick before I let
you jump in Hank so how does an atheist
get morals if not being handed down to
them by the Lord everyone has morals and
if you follow the morals handed down to
you by the Lord you'd end up in jail
right a lot of a lot of eye for an eye
kind of thing I mean yeah you know
killing your kids and stuff and there's
actually that's happening now a lot of
people with the faith healing and stuff
they're not getting their kids the
medical treatment that they need and you
know whenever they're obviously you know
repeat offenders because they let one
kid die and then another kid dies then
they go to jail you know the first one's
okay yeah but I mean it's it's happening
now people are following you know the
word of the Bible and that's happening
yeah so so what do you make of the of
the quarter of the Liberals because
that's the number here that the
conservative thing all right I get it
like if you're more conservative and
you're more religious then I can
understand this I don't agree with it
but I can understand it the a quarter of
liberals that's a lot I'd like to see
how they broke down the word liberal
because liberal doesn't necessarily mean
not religious no you know so a lot of
liberals actually are do still identify
with some kind of faith and I think
people in general it's human that you
want to see yourself reflected in in
others and those are the ones you
gravitate toward more towards anyways
because America is such a I would say a
spirit has such a strong spiritual
Foundation that it just seeps into
everyone's way of life and so when they
run into someone who completely rejects
all of that and we're and we're talking
not just Christianity which I think is
probably the most prevalent of religions
here but when they're like women you
don't even believe in Oprah and energies
of the universe and like you know and
all of it like that's we like why who
did this to you what's happening to you
in your life to make you turn out so
horrible yeah yeah I mean I think
another thing about this is like
whenever you think about the word
liberal a lot of times whenever you
identify as something you expect that
everyone in that you know category is
like this awesome you know open-minded
free thinking person and I've learned
the hard way that even within the
atheist Community you can't expect all
of them to be open-minded and free
thinking interesting so there is
discrimination even within the aps
Community it's because you're human
beings you know just because you're a
liberal or a conservative or an atheist
or a Christian or whatever I mean
there's still those human tendencies
that make certain people horrible I mean
you can be a bad person and an atheist
or a Christian or whatever you know
there's there's bad people everywhere
how much of this do you guys think has
to do with tradition more than religion
per se because I could see I'm not
religious per se but I do like some of
the Traditions like during past over I
will have a Seder I like the tradition
of it it doesn't have a religious
connotation to me really so I could see
why someone would say oh I don't want
someone coming into my family who's not
going to care about the the Traditions
more than the religion itself am I uh a
bit of a jump or something I mean I can
see that yeah I can see that being a
thing but I think most of it is just
people are
scared of atheists yeah I mean even if
you sat there and said I'm not religious
that would go over completely
differently than saying I'm an atheist
right you know like I've heard stories
people you know saying that they're not
religious or that they're not atheists
and and the response is well I can
understand you not believing in God but
an atheist it's like
they think atheists are like nihilists
or something like they have no belief
system whatsoever is that well I mean
maybe but that's just a misconception
what is your personal definition how why
do you label yourself an atheist I don't
believe in God okay that's it like
that's always
do you think we need more atheists to
come out of the closet I've talked about
this a couple times when we've done this
before that you know even somebody like
Barney Frank who was was open no well so
he was openly gay in the 80s in Congress
I think he came out in like 1982 or 1983
had an incredibly uh proficient career
and then he didn't come out as an
atheist until about a month after he
resigned last year so atheists are
actually behind gay people in the in
their uh exposure so you're what you're
trying to say Dave is that atheist
rights are the new Trans rights is what
you're trying to say trans people are
just getting their rights but there's
not even time for that I'm sorry we're
really pushing I know yeah because we
can just deal with one thing at a time
exactly uh to answer a question yes I
think it's very important because I I do
believe that atheists are misrepresented
and misunderstood in this country tree
yeah I assume that you think more
atheists need to as someone that
publicly is doing this all the time yeah
I mean there's such a stigma and I feel
like the only way to get rid of that is
to you know say hey I'm a normal
person and I'm an atheist you know it's
not that hard it's not that hard there
you go all right we got one more for you
and this one uh I am very happy about
and uh we're gonna file this under
pretty damn obvious uh a new study by
Gallup shows that people's faith in
mainstream television news is at an
all-time low let's look at some numbers
on public faith and TV
so 10 now 10 one out of ten people say
they have a great deal of confidence in
TV News Eight percent say they have
quite a lot of confidence so what you
can see here is that starting in 1993
there has just been a precipitous
decline in the amount of people that
believe uh in mainstream news something
happened you know they started this in
93 but there were like major drop to 93
to 94. I'm not exactly sure you know
what that might have something to do
with I wonder is that uh O.J Simpson
that's when cable news really went nuts
that was 1994.
um so maybe it has something to do with
that when when cable news and mainstream
news got so Sensational
um does any of this surprise this seems
good to me as an online news guy this
seems all good to me because this is
what I've been saying forever and this
is why I do what I do because we can
tell the truth here and we don't have
something in our ear with uh Network
executive telling us what to say and
teleprompters and all that so uh are you
guys on the on the bandwagon here that
this is this is all good this is not
surprising you right now my family and
every other Asian family lost the faith
in 95 when CBS fired Connie Chung okay
they were they were done they were out
so but in all seriousness in the last 20
years you're right it is the expansion
you know when uh Al Gore invented the
Internet yes um yeah yeah there was uh
he he opened up uh the dialogues were
opened up and so you don't have your uh
middle-aged white guy no offense you're
not middle aged or white I will be 38.
uh you know presenting you this
information that you're supposed to just
take at face value someone can tell you
something and then you can uh go
elsewhere to uh read criticisms about it
to read other opinions differing
opinions to read arguments about it and
then form your own and I think it's this
new generation of people that were
raised just to be a little skeptical of
authority uh We're not gonna just take
the broadcast newscasters at at face
value yeah do you think this is more
because mainstream news just sucks or
because online news is good good or
maybe you don't agree with either well I
think both and um like I mean I don't
think it's surprising to anyone it's not
news to anyone yeah that's news people
don't trust media I mean it's gone down
a lot but as far as the internet goes
that hasn't been a very well trusted
media either I mean it's not as low now
I think finally the TV news has dropped
below the internet right the internet's
never really been incredibly High either
and I mean as far as newspapers goes
that's been the people of the internet
are high but the yeah yeah I mean like
newspapers are the most trusted but the
amount of circulation of like printing
new newspapers and stuff like people
aren't doing that anymore it's gone down
so much that they actually think it
might not even be a thing in five to ten
years anymore yeah um so I really think
the internet is going to be the biggest
form of media and it's I mean I know
that there's a lot of troll websites and
there's a lot of misinformation out
there and everybody knows anyone can go
on Wikipedia and edit and I think like
part of that has kind of made people
more distrustful of the internet but I
mean there are so many different
websites out there that you can go to
that have you know researched and
peer-reviewed articles it just takes a
little bit of work right so how do you
do that because there is so much that
that's what I think is the interesting
part you know you have three cable news
channels and one's working for the
Democratic party one's working for the
Republican party and I don't know what
CNN CNN still looking for the plane
um but what what do you do because
there's so much information how do you
decide who to trust it's tough right
yeah it's true I mean when it depending
on what the issue is I always read the
differing opinions as I was mentioning
earlier and I I guess I bounce it off of
my own moral compass right what do I
believe and what's important to me and
then I take from it what I will I mean
unless are you implying that the
newscasters like you know whomever is
reading on the evening news is straight
up lying to you well they're all owned
by giant corporations
no I was just going to say there's a
very small group of people that control
pretty much 90 of what you see yeah on
the news so I mean if you have actually
seen different videos where people have
lined up they introduce like the
introductory segments to different news
shows and they all say the same line
like for Easter they're like oh we're
hockey this year like but like But like
everyone says the same thing at the same
time on the same year yeah but then like
and I saw a video where a lot of these
were placed together so it's almost like
they're all scripted in a different way
and you know like that is that's going
to shake your confidence a lot because
it's all planned out they're all saying
the same things and even whenever they
disagree you kind of Wonder was that
planned like that I don't think there's
necessarily like the secret cabal of
Five Guys that are sitting in a room
disseminating this information because
as Carl Sagan said extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence and I
have no evidence of that although it
seems like it but that's not evidence
right seeming is not evident no but
that's not speculation I wish Dave yeah
but is there is there anyone in the
mainstream news that when you watch do
you trust them I don't think they're
sitting there lying like I don't think
people are necessarily like
automatically no sometimes they do for
sure I mean you watch Chris Matthews on
MSNBC he's had every opinion about
everything and and discounts what he
says the week before constantly so yeah
some of them are lying but the rest of
them I think are just a lot of them are
they're just TV people who hand someone
hands and something and they read it and
that's it is there anyone that you watch
that you really in mainstream news that
you watch that you really feel like is
telling you absolutely not yeah no I get
all my information from the internet and
if it's something that seems sketchy to
me I'll definitely look further into it
yeah you know I I use more than one
source and TV just does not seem like
something that I would ever want to use
you crazy I'm using more than one source
geez something else she doesn't have
faith in okay right
it's a lack of moral
evil yeah really who do you trust is
there someone that you trust that we all
know Anderson Cooper he's keeping them
honest isn't he he is he's a good
interviewer and I don't think he's
necessarily presenting information I
think he's just asking the hard
questions with regards to whoever is
prominent in the media but I take my
news of the green assault I was going to
say I like Diane Sawyer I like everyone
in the Good Morning America team because
they're fun you know and and they're
generally pretty light-hearted if I want
something serious hitting you know
something I will I will turn to a more
credible like online newspaper or
something with a more investigative
angle and by the way if you want an
example of what you were talking about
about how it seems like they're all
doing this In Cahoots with each other
you know net neutrality which we and The
Young Turks talked about constantly
which is really basically pretty much
after the NSA it's the most important
thing that's happening in the country
right now out because we need equal
access to the internet so that these
giant corporations can start throttling
what you can and can't watch the network
news and even Caitlin who's barely
covered it at all we covered it here
because it's important to us but that's
the whole point because eventually they
could start slowing it down for us and
then you'd only get your information
from the very same people who aren't
covering it so filtered there's so many
times I see something huge going on you
know somebody being you know persecuted
another country for their lack of
beliefs or different beliefs and that's
never on the news the only time I ever
get that information is because it's you
know something that my friends are
posting about on Twitter or you know
it's like the information that I find to
be incredibly important a lot of times
there's nowhere to be found you guys
happen to remember that with maybe one
of these guys remember also when the
whole thing was happening in Egypt and
to rear square and and uh we were
showing but CNN all day was showing that
trial does anyone remember what
trial that was anyone there was some
stupid another just some trial another
trials a woman it was a woman that I'm
sure killed somebody or something
something and CNN was literally showing
the trial there is nothing more
driveless and minutia based than showing
eight hours of a trial and CNN was
showing to rear Square in a little box
while they were showing the trial and
nothing happens in in a trial all day
long and it's all anyway anywho
I hope you learned a little something
here and that you felt we were being
honest because that's what we're trying
to do so I want to thank Jacqueline
Glenn and Hank Chen they are both big
YouTubers so check out their channels
which are right down below and they're
on Twitter and all that good stuff and
we will do it again next week thanks
guys